welcome back everyone in the last video
I gave you kind of a brief overview of
how extremely seeking control works on a
really really simple example of a static
objective function you're trying to
optimize with some control and put you
so we had this picture here with some
objective function J some quadratic
objective you're trying to maximize here
the x-axis is your control knob you that
you get to jiggle and the basic idea of
extremely seeking control is even if you
have some best estimate you hat you want
to be adding a little bit of a
sinusoidal perturbation to that to probe
this objective function and if that
objective function if when you swing
your your your control to the right if
your objective goes up you should have a
signal that tells you go more to the
right and if you're to the right of the
objective function and you swing to the
right and your objective goes down you
should have a correcting signal saying
hey move more to the left because that's
where your optimum is extremists seeking
control is really that simple but there
is a lot of depth when you apply this to
dynamical systems so Miroslav Christic
and collaborators at UCSD have developed
lots of kind of guarantees for when
extreme seeking control will and will
not work when it's applied to dynamical
system so very powerful very useful
basic diagram here for a static
objective function but this also applies
to dynamical systems and then here is
kind of that diagram that I drew before
where you have some kind of an input
perturbation some sine omega t where
omega is faster than the slow
disturbances to your system or faster
than this cost function is changing in
time but where this Omega is slow
compared to the internal dynamics of
your system so you want your system to
respond fast to these sinusoidal
perturbations but you want the the
objective function you're trying to
track to be slow in time and so
basically you put in this additional
sinusoidal perturbation to your best
estimate you hat you get some
corresponding sinusoidal outputs J
you have to high-pass filter that to get
rid of this this mean component here
this average component so you high-pass
filter it just to get the purely a Silla
Tory part in row you multiply that by
your sinusoidal perturbation possibly
with a phase shift that gives you this
demodulated signal C and C is the
quantity that is more or less positive
when I'm to the left of the optimum and
negative when I'm to the right of the
optimum and I continuously integrate
that see that demodulated signal C into
my best estimate U hat using this
integrator block here so if I'm to the
left of this optimum point then C is
positive and I integrate that up and I
move to the right and move to the right
move to the right until I converge if
I'm to the right of the optimum then C
is negative and I integrate that
negative value moves to the left move
left move left until I hit this optimum
and so in both cases if I have this
simple picture here I converge to the
global optimum solution sorry that this
optimum solution and then I stay put now
if there were multiple peaks to this you
would only converge to a local optimum
that you're closest to okay so that
that's a caveat and what this looks like
this is for a simulated example that
we're going to cook up in a minute
I have this this basic quadratic
landscape here and what I'm going to do
is I run my experience I can control
starting from the left of the optimum
and you see that very rapidly there's a
sinusoidal perturbation on top of my
best control estimate u hat and that
sinusoidal input gives rise to a
sinusoidal output in the objective
function and what happens is over time
because I started to the left
this jiggle walks me to the right in you
it walks me from zero to I guess five
and five appears to be the optimizing
control input which gives me the maximum
of J and one thing that's really
interesting notice that these
oscillations and J are bigger the
farther I am from the peak so the higher
the slope the bigger the oscillations in
J and the faster my U increases and then
as I get close to the optimum u
increases less rapidly because the slope
is tail it is
tailing off and also notice that my
perturbation output in J becomes very
very very small in fact it becomes on
the order of a squared where a is the
magnitude of this input ripple okay so
this input ripple has amplitude a then
as you approach the peak if this is a
quadratic cost function then the J
oscillation goes like a squared so this
is a small perturbation then essentially
what happens is as you approach the peak
your sinusoidal input also doesn't give
you much loss in performance because you
wouldn't want this J to be oscillating a
bunch around the optimal value so it's
nice that as as you approach the optimum
value these perturbations and J decrease
that's really good okay so you get this
kind of rock-solid peak performance in a
very short amount of time with this
sinusoidal oscillation okay so this is
the basic architecture of extreme so you
can control on a on a data set now what
we're going to do is we're going to code
this up with this type of cost function
and we're actually going to reproduce
these curves so that's what we're gonna
do now okay
so let's do this in MATLAB in MATLAB I
have a script here you can download this
from the internet this is also in our
data-driven science and engineering book
what we're going to do is basically cook
up our own cost function which is static
and then we're going to write the
extreme seeking control algorithm to
optimize for the status static objective
function so in this case my objective
function J is 25 minus v minus u
quantity squared okay I had this as a
function of U and T so that in the
future what I can do is I can make this
setpoint time varying so I can make it
move in time but for now this is just
static in time okay so let's let's
actually run this okay and now let's
also plot what that objective function
is for you between minus 5 and 15 u
between minus 5 and 15 and I'm plotting
it on a black background
basically you can see that this this
objective function J has a peak value at
U equals five and then it quadratically
falls off as u goes away from five okay
so this is a very very simple cost
function well behaved but illustrates
the points okay so now what we're going
to do is we're actually going to start
designing an extreme seeking control
okay so what do I need to design an
extremely seeking control I need to
design the the sampling frequency so I
need to know what how fast I'm actually
sampling this system essentially I'm
going to act like this is a
discrete-time system where I take
samples at fixed Delta T's so DT equals
one over the frequency which I've chosen
to be I guess 20 Hertz I need to pick a
time for how long I'm going to run my
simulation so in this case T equals 10 I
need an amplitude of my sinusoidal
perturbation that's big a here so point
two and then what I need is an Omega
which is my frequency in Hertz
okay so Omega is 10 times 2 times pi or
I guess 10 Hertz here and I'm gonna use
zero phase remember when I injected my
sine wave and then I multiplied by that
same sine wave there was that little
plus fee that phase I'm gonna choose
phase equal to zero in this case and I'm
going to have an integration gain of
five for my integrator okay so basically
I picked my my oscillation frequency to
be 10 Hertz I have an integral gain K
equals 5 if I make this bigger or
smaller I'll track faster or slower so
if this gets too big your system will go
unstable if this is too small your
system will track too slowly okay so
this is one of the parameters that I
would actually play around with is this
K
I would also play around with this Omega
frequency I'd make another faster or
slower depending on the system and then
I have to build that high-pass filter
remember I have these sinusoidal outputs
in my objective function but they're at
some steady state mean and I want to
subtract that mean with this high-pass
filter
I'm going to design a butter wolf worth
filter first order with a cut-off
frequency of 2 Hertz okay so my my Omega
frequency was 10 Hertz and so I'm gonna
design my high pass filter to cut off
anything that's that's lower than 2
Hertz so it's going to only give me back
my my output oscillation okay in that
lab you can read about you can kind of
play at this code or read about the
butter in the help files but basically
I'm just designing a discrete-time
Butterworth filter here and now I'm
gonna set up my loop this loop is
basically a big for loop where I'm
walking through each Delta t of the
simulation so for each I you know up
until the the final duration of my
simulation what I'm going to do is I'm
going to measure what J is at that
particular value of U and then I'm going
to do this sinusoidal jiggle I'm going
to high-pass filter the output multiply
them and integrate that into my my U hat
so this is basically just a big for loop
that does everything that that diagram
described before so I have a high-pass
filter I have to update my filtered
estimates here in this loop I have to
design I have to build this see this
demodulated so my high pass filtered
output I multiply by my sine wave and
then I integrate that I add C times my
integral gain times delta T to my best
estimate to get my new best estimate you
had so I'm jiggling this thing and if C
is positive I add that positive value
times K times delta T to get a new u hat
and then again I add my sinusoidal
perturbation at the end and everything
loops through so this is just a for loop
for the extreme of seeking control you
could also design this in Simulink which
I'll show you later it's actually easier
to do this with blocks and Simulink but
I wanted to show you the for loop
basically you can have this code running
at every delta T of some discrete-time
controller so I can build a little
discrete-time controller I can clip it
on to the inputs and out
of my system and this would be running
in the background at every Delta team so
that's why I want to show you that you
can write this in discrete time I just
ran it it runs super fast and now I'm
just gonna run some plotting commands so
I'm going to plot the the best estimate
you had in red so this is the best
estimate tracking in time I add to that
my sinusoidal perturbation this little
jiggly white curve and here's my
objective function J evolving in time as
well so this is just showing that you
can quickly reproduce these results with
you know you know about 50 lines of code
now what's kind of cool about this I'm
using something called in MATLAB it's
called link axes so my subplot one I
call axis one my subplot two I call
access to and then I run this command
called link axes so I link axis one with
access to and I link there x-axis so
what I can do if I want is if i zoom in
on one of these let's say I want to zoom
in on this first three seconds up here
it seems in the x-axis on both this is
super cool okay and so now when you zoom
in you can actually see this red curve
the best estimate you is just increasing
and to that I'm adding this sinusoidal
perturbation and I get my sinusoidal
output perturbation here for my
objective function and the magnitude of
that is bigger when I'm at a higher
slope so I walk up faster and then as
the slope becomes closer to zero these
decrease and my u changes less rapidly
okay so takeaway here extreme seeking
control is very easy to code up you can
do this in discrete time so I can
basically have this running every little
delta T of some digital controller all I
need is to design a frequency filter I
need to inject a sinusoidal input at
some given frequency at some magnitude
and I have some gain K that I can play
with so I told you that this would chain
if I changed K equals five let's try
that let's say I make this integral gain
one so I make it five times smaller what
do you expect will happen well I expect
it should track slower so I'm gonna run
this I'm gonna go back down to my
plotting commands okay and you see that
we are approaching u equals five but
we're doing it much much much more
slowly because my my update to u hat I'm
multiplying it by a smaller number so
I'm being less aggressive when I update
u hat and so it takes a lot longer but
this could be dangerous what if I we
know for example that in lots of systems
if my if my integral gain is too large I
can destabilize it so let's see what
happens if I make K equals 10 so I've
made it bigger than it was before now
I'm gonna run this okay now I get
SuperDuper fast tracking but it's
looking a little wonky it's not pure
sinusoids anymore so we're actually
moving faster than our high-pass filter
can filter out the change so that's
what's happening here is our high-pass
filter now is allowing some of this fast
rise in j and it's gonna eventually mess
everything up so let's try this again I
actually don't know when this is gonna
break or how it's gonna break so let's
try it k equals 20
okay now things are going crazy just
like lots and lots of stuff happening
but it does track this very rapidly and
I'm guessing at some point I can
actually destabilize the system and boom
it blows up to infinity
okay so long story short this is a knob
that you actually get to tune so I tuned
it to K equals 5 because it gives a nice
smooth increase without any of that
jagged stuff in the beginning it would
also be interesting to try and change
these frequencies so I could change my
sinusoidal perturbation frequency I
could change the phase I could change
the amplitude these will all have a
different effect so let's say I want to
make my amplitude bigger I make it
amplitude instead of point
- I may get one okay so now again I have
faster rise because I have a much bigger
signal telling me what to do except now
it's such a large perturbation that even
when I met the optimum value I can see
my J function is swinging a lot more
than it used to so these are big
perturbations and so that might be
something I want to avoid is having a
really big a so there's a trade-off
between how big your ripple your
sinusoidal perturbation is and the
integral gain with which you accumulate
that new information about moving right
or left I'm going to move this back down
to point two so you basically see these
are the knobs you get to play with in
the real world in practice Omega might
be kind of determined by the dynamics
and time scales of your system so if I
have system dynamics that are fast and I
have disturbances or parameters that are
changing slowly I have to choose my my
sinusoidal perturbation to be somewhere
in the middle of those two okay so that
one is usually kind of determined by the
time scales with the system sometimes in
power electronics you have a sinusoidal
perturbation at 60 Hertz anyway and so
you kind of have to use that 60 Hertz
perturbation and so sometimes this this
frequency Omega is given to you okay and
maybe also in that case the amplitude a
is also handed to you okay so very
simple architecture based on this kind
of feedback you perturb your input you
measure your perturbative output and
then you walk your best estimate of you
hat in the right direction to seek to
seek that optimum okay thank you